hello developers my name is matt rabel
today i'd like to show you how to
develop a reactive microservices
architecture using jhipster if you're a
java developer you're probably very
aware that microservices have really
taken off in the last five or six years
mostly because of spring boot and spring
boot and spring cloud have really made
it easy to develop a micro services
architecture and with spring boot 2.0
they actually brought spring webflux to
the table so let's show you how to use
those frameworks to develop a
microservices architecture using the
awesome open source project jhipster
let's giddy up
this screencast is based on a blog post
that i wrote back in january and if you
click on the change log you'll see that
i actually updated it recently for
jhipster 7.0.1 and so what this blog
post goes through is talking about
spring boot spring security and how
jhipster marries all those together to
make it easy to generate microservice
architectures spring boot introduced a
framework called webflux to complement
spring nbc if you're familiar with
spring nbc it works great for developing
many types of java applications and apis
spring webflux makes it so you can use
reactive programming to make your system
scale more on less hardware and so if
you have over 500 requests per second
you might want to look into spring
webflux otherwise spring mvc will
probably have the same performance up
until 500 requests per second so if you
read through this article you'll see
there's a number of topics covered we're
going to build a reactive microservices
architecture we'll define it with jdl
that's jhipster's domain language we'll
run it we'll test it we'll prepare it
for production we'll make it use octa
for oidc then we'll create docker images
and run it using docker compose and then
i'll talk a little bit about why or why
not you might want to go reactive at the
end so if you scroll down a bit you'll
see there's some examples of spring
mvc's code for creating points for
instance you'll see it looks pretty
straightforward very synchronous in a
sense and then the same code with spring
webflux you'll see it's it's more fluid
it's uses streams api for the most part
and you know it does a flat map and then
map and then returns everything from
that so it's non-blocking and it makes
things a little bit more difficult to
wrap your head around but like i said
you'll get much better performance at
high load so you will need to have java
11 and docker install to do this
tutorial and i'll show you you may need
to tweak your docker settings to have a
bunch of more ram than is allocated by
default i think it's two gigs by default
i typically run with anywhere from six
to ten so i do have a 64 gig ram laptop
a macbook pro and so if you're able to
or you're not able to do the same sort
of things it might be because your
memory isn't quite there so you can see
you can find the completed source code
for this example on github and i have
that open in my browser here and i also
have a demo.adoc open in that folder so
this is the instructions that i'm going
to use that basically just condense the
blog post so it's you know easy to
follow and i'm not copying and pasting
out of the blog post so i wrote it in
ascii doctor and you can see i can use
my handy dandy ascii doctor plugin for
my browser and it renders quite nicely
there so i'll put that on the left and
then go down here so the first thing
you'll need to do is install jhipster
generator jhipster and i already have
installed so i don't need to do that i
can just run jhipster version and you'll
see i have the 7.0.1 version and then
java 11 and node 14. so you'll need all
those installed to do this tutorial and
then i will create a reactive stack
directory and take does makeder and cds
into it so it's all in one command it
comes with oh my zsh and then i will go
ahead and do git init and the reason i'm
doing this is because jhipster will
create different directories for each
application in my microservices
architecture and if it doesn't detect
it's in a git repository it'll create
you know git repos for each one of those
and we're just going to do it all in a
mono repo i'm going to use this jdl to
generate our micro services architecture
you can see at the top here we have an
application that is a gateway and this
will use spring cloud gateway so in
spring boot 2.4 spring cloud gateway is
the best way to do any sort of gateway
they've deprecated the use of zuul in
spring cloud so you can no longer use
that to develop a gateway with spring
nbc there is an open issue to add spring
nvc support to spring cloud gateway but
basically reactive is forced for a
gateway we're using oauth 2 for
authentication we're using gradle and
i'm going to use vue because that's new
in jhipster7 kind of fun to use a new
web framework and then test frameworks
as cyprus and cyprus is new in jhipster7
as well before we just had protractor
support and then you'll see here we have
a blog that we're also going to develop
and that is going to be a microservice
and you must make sure that the
authentication type matches right so
that's where we're using oauth2 again
and then we also have a store so the
store is going to be a microservice as
well the difference is the blog is going
to use neo4j the store is going to use
mongodb we're going to use eureka for
service discovery so we'll use jhipster
registry to actually allow all these
applications to talk to each other and
then we'll have a number of entities so
you can see we have a blog a post and a
tag and those are all for the blog
microservice if we were to go up to the
blog microservice you can see them
listed right there and then we also have
a product that's just used by the store
microservice and then we have
relationships the blog has a mini to one
relationship to user as well as post to
a blog and then many too many posts can
have many tags and then we have
pagination rules here at the bottom as
well as a microservice indicator and a
deployment type for docker compose with
this architecture definition we can
actually create everything so we'll go
ahead and copy that and just to let you
know there's also a jdl samples
repository so in fact we don't even need
to copy this because it's the same one
that's in the jdl samples repository so
when you type jhipsterjdl it'll look
first on your file system and that'll
look in that samples repository so a
shortcut we can do is jhipster jdl
reactive ms and even though we don't
have it locally it'll pull it from the
samples repository you can see this took
a couple minutes to generate everything
that time will depend on your hardware
your internet connection as well as
whether you're recording a video or not
so usually this is around a minute but
it does create all the applications in
parallel so it's as fast as it can be
the npm install is what really slows
things down so that does happen for the
gateway because that's where all the ui
code is and so now that we have
everything generated we can start it and
one of the things that jhipster does is
it generates docker containers for all
the different things you need that
aren't quite in the project so we have
key cloak involved we have neo4j we have
mongodb and we have the jhipster
registry so first of all i just want to
look at the jdl that was downloaded to
make sure that matches you know what we
looked at earlier and also to make you
aware that reactive true is the basic
difference between spring nbc and spring
webflux that's all you need to do to be
reactive in your micro services so you
can see it's there for the gateway the
blog and the store and so we can go into
the gateway to start things off
and we can start up key cloak the long
way is docker compose dash f source main
docker
and it'll start up key clock for you i
also have a number of shortcuts
installed with an oh my zsh plug-in that
jhipster provides so from now on i'm
just going to use those commands so i
can start up postgres with jh postgres
up and then jh registry up and one cool
command you might find useful is jh
registry logs that will tail the log so
you can see if the registry is starting
up and all that that should be enough
that we can start the gateway and then
we'll go in and start the blog as well
and we have neo4j in this so we need to
do jh neo4j up start that docker
container then we'll run our app and
then the last one is the store that uses
[ __ ] so jh [ __ ] up oh we're still in
the blog go to the store jh [ __ ] up and
then start that one with gradle w while
those are all starting up i'm going to
open up a new terminal just to make sure
i have key cloak in my etsy hosts file
so you'll see i do at one two seven zero
zero one that is necessary when you're
running everything in docker right now
we're running everything you know just
using gradle so it's not an issue yet
but when you get to the docker phase
what will happen is it'll redirect to
key cloak in the url and so that's why
you need it here if you have a better
way and you know docker networking then
please let us know if we can fix that
but we haven't found a better solution
than that so now everything's up and
running we should be able to log in
localhost 8080 make that a bit bigger
and it redirects us to keep cloak admin
admin you can also use user user and now
we're logged in if we were to look at
our entities we can see we have a blog
and we have some data in there that's
from a previous demo i did so i can
delete that you always got to practice
before these things right and look we
even have a product in there let's add a
new product i happen to like beer
belgian beer which can be a bit pricier
so we'll say ten dollars for ten percent
add this icon here you can see it even
saves images in your database that
alerts coming from view since we're
using view on the front end and
everything appears to be working if we
go to the administration we can see the
current routes under the gateway we can
see the metrics for all the timings and
how fast things are happening we can
also look at the health of the project
and see that everything's up
everything's working nicely and there's
also swagger if we wanted to actually
you know execute some commands in our
browser we could uh check out the user's
account information for instance execute
it and you'll see not only the curl
command but you'll see the response
there so that's all working quite nicely
and we can log out here heat cloak is a
superb oidc and oauth solution it's open
source you can run it in a docker
container i have no problems with it i
admire it very much and i love to use it
with jhipster however going to
production you might need something
that's always on and maybe you don't
want to manage your identity provider so
that's where octa kind of comes into
play and we use spring security to do
our oauth implementation so everything
happens on the back end and people have
asked about this why don't you do it on
the front end why don't you do the
authorization in view or angular or
react well part of the reason is that if
we had to do it on the front end then
we'd have to do it in all three of those
various frameworks and they might not
have oidc libraries that make it happen
second of all if you're storing the
access token on the client it's not
quite as secure so that's why we do it
on the back end we do all the olaf flows
there all the oidc logic and it just
works great and we don't have to worry
about the front end you know coding each
of those to make it work so spring cloud
gateway makes it very easy to relay an
access token between a gateway and the
downstream microservices so it's just
five lines of yaml that you can see
there it's just a token relay filter
that makes it very easy to implement and
very easy to use and so to make this
work with octa first of all we'll shut
all these down we can even take key
cloak down with jh key cloak down and in
the gateway project itself we use the
octa cli so if you don't have the cli
installed
cli.octa.com that'll get you the
information that you need to install it
and i'm going to run octa register it'll
prompt me for my first name my email and
they'll create a new octa organization
for me and it'll prompt me to verify
that that email works then i can get my
verification code for my email
paste it in
and it's created everything for me and
you can see you can set your password
opening this link so i'll go ahead and
do that
there we are now we're all set up we can
close that tab and we can run octa apps
create jhipster this will prompt us for
an application name so i'll say reactive
microservices and it'll already know
what we need for the redirect uris you
can see we have the first one is for our
gateway app that's going to handle the
oidc authentication and this is what
spring security expects we use oidc at
the end instead of octa because we want
to be generic between key cloak and octa
and then this one is for the jhipster
registry so you can use oauth and oidc
to log in there as well so we'll just
accept the defaults and accept the post
logout redirect uris as well so you can
see it not only created an app for us
right that's right here and it has a
client id but it also created groups for
role admin and role user which jhipster
expects and then it added our user into
those so if we log in with our user will
be an admin and then it writes it to
this dot octa env file so you can see
our issuer uri our client id and our
client secret and the reason we put it
into an env file is we don't want to
chuck it into source control so that's
what we're trying to prevent so we can
add these settings to our jhipster
registries configuration and what it
will do is share those for all the
microservices and how it does that is
spring cloud config it's embedded and
jhips are registry and so all the apps
will look for configuration in spring
cloud config and use it if it's there so
we can take this value right here and
we'll open up a new terminal and we'll
go into source main docker that
application.yml and go down to the
bottom and we'll add it there and then
we can grab our values from right up
here paste that in there so now we
should be good to go and if we stop j
history registry or jh registry down
that stops the j hipster registry and i
have seen this error before so when it
happens you don't really have to worry
about it you can do docker ps to see
what's still running jhipster registry
is not in there so you can do jhipster
registry up and now make sure nothing's
running for java kill all our
microservices and then we can start
everything up again so in our gateway
we'll do a gradle there
and in our blog we'll start that as well
and one thing i forgot to mention even
though we installed cypress we didn't
run it so on the gateway when using key
cloak you could actually run npm run e2e
from the command line in that same
gateway directory and it would do
everything and make sure everything
worked now that everything started we
can hit localhost 8080 make that a bit
bigger and sign in you'll see it took us
to octa and it logged us in so you're
like how did that happen it's because
we've logged in before remember when we
changed our password so if we were to
use an incognito window and do localhost
8080 this time you would actually see
the octa login screen so i can enter my
credentials you don't need your whole
email you just need the part before that
and then you can log in that way and of
course all the entities are still there
and all the data is still there because
we didn't change anything right we
didn't change any of the back end code
you'll see you can use cypress to test
octa so i didn't show you how you do it
with key cloak but it's very easy just
run this command npm run e2e from the
front end gateway so now we'll do is
we'll stop all of our docker containers
because we're going to run everything in
docker now so back here stop all our
apps and stop all our docker containers
verify they're all stopped with docker
ps and now we can build docker
containers for each of our apps so we
use this gradle command pass in the prod
profile and boot jar and jib docker
build so jib is the one that's going to
be doing the docker build so we'll start
with the store and we'll do the blog and
then we'll do a gateway
while those are all building what we'll
do is we'll modify the docker compose
file that was generated first of all we
don't need key cloak anymore because
we're just going to run with octa and
then there's a different place where we
have to specify the octave values here
this is in docker compose central server
config application.yaml so i will go
ahead and open everything up in my ide
so the first thing is to remove key
cloak from docker compose just down at
the bottom here needing that and then in
the gateway project that's where we had
the settings before so that was under
source main docker and grab those values
and then in here in the central server
config it's just a different location
when you're running everything with
docker compose we'll put the values
there and then let's see if all our
containers have been built we still have
the gateway going here now our gateway
is completed so we can use docker
compose up we'll have to cd into the
docker compose directory
and you can put dash d on the end and
then you won't see any output but i like
doing it this way without the dash d and
you can basically see the logs from all
the different containers starting up so
it looks like everything started we can
open a new incognito window and the
first thing is to check on the registry
to see if they say everything started so
8761 you'll notice it takes us to octa
to log in and it says everything's up we
could also look at the configuration and
you'll see our octa values are in there
and there is a way to encrypt those
values so you aren't checking in client
secrets i'll show you that in a future
tutorial right now i want to go to
localhost 8080 prove that everything
works since we already logged into octa
it should bring us back here yep and
we're seeing tags we're seeing products
and everything's working like we expect
it to so you might be wondering about
hotline we do have kotlin support for
jhipster so there's a kotlin blueprint
and you can install it using npm install
dash g generator j hipster kotlin at the
time that i wrote this demo there wasn't
support but if you'll notice if you go
to the releases page it does have
support for jhipster 7.0.1 unfortunately
when i tried this specific jdl there
were some issues so hopefully those will
be fixed very soon you might be
wondering how do i deploy this to the
cloud well jhipster has support for aws
azure heroku and google cloud platform
so it's pretty easy to actually get it
to those end points the problem is if
you're actually deploying to say heroku
you'll have to deploy each individual
app and probably what you want to use is
something like kubernetes right to
basically do it all so in a future video
i'll show you how to do that but it's
pretty easy all you need to do is run
the kubernetes generator for jhipster so
that's jhipster k8 or jhipster
kubernetes if you want to spell it out
ray sang and i did a talk on this and
you can uh you can see it's right here
embedded in my demo it's also embedded
in the blog post so if you start
watching at 4618 you'll see rey take a
very similar architecture to this one
and put it up on google cloud and then
you might be asking yourself you know
should you go reactive or should you
wait for project loom so spring nbc is
probably good enough for most crud apps
especially if you have less than 500
requests a second but if you're dealing
with you know millions of customers and
millions of dollars a month for your
cloud bill and you can make things
faster than maybe look into spring wood
flux project loom might make it so the
non-reactive code actually works as fast
as the reactive code you might want to
look into that i think that might be a
couple years out from what i've seen
companies are having a hard time even
jumping from java 8 to java 11 so
project loom might be in java 17 and if
it is and you can upgrade great try it
out let me know how it works currently
i'm investing my knowledge in reactive
and i'll keep my eye on project bloom i
think the beauty is that if you know the
non-reactive stuff which you probably do
then you don't need to learn anything
new for project loom and by learning how
to do spring web flex and code in
reactive style you will actually make
yourself more aware of cool things like
the stream api so you can find this code
for this example on my repo at java
micro services examples under octa
developer and then it's in the reactive
jhipster directory so if you were to go
level up you can see there's regular
jhipster there's spring boot and spring
cloud and spring cloud gateway and of
course you can find the blog post itself
reactive java microservices i think if
you google for just that it'll come up
so hopefully you've enjoyed this
screencast if you liked it follow my
team on twitter octadev i'm at mrabel we
also have a youtube channel at octadev
on twitter so subscribe and enjoy more
videos like this one